>> PARLANTE: So, I just want to make a couple
sort of concluding remarks and say, tell you
some stuff about Python. I want to show you
like, one more Python feature I've been kind
of holding back on and then we'll let you
go to--go back coding or go have some more
free food. So, the first thing I'm going to
do--oh, I just have to establish the point
of order. All right, so, what does readable
code mean? Let's think about that. It's like,
well, I would say it's code that if someone
who didn't write it, they kind of look down
at the printout and they think for like a--they
can kind of see what it does. And I'm willing
to pause; we'd agree that readable code, that's
a good thing. All right, we like code that
you can read. All right, so I'm just going
to table that, I'm going to put that on the
side for use later into this discussion. All
right, so I want to show you this feature.
This is a feature I kind of thought about
showing you. But there was just so much going
on. This was just one feature too many for
our discussion. But this is something that
you're now ready to use. So, we've done a
lot of stuff with lists. So, I'm going to
set up a list here. I'll have like, you know,
"aaaa", "bb" and "ccccc", that's it. All right,
there's a list of strings. And suppose I wanted
to have a list of their lengths. We've seen
how--I could've said, "Well, you know, result,
the sequel to the empty list." Then I could've--you
know, I looped through list A and added stuff
to the result list like. And you know what?
That is a fine technique. But Python has a
feature called a list comprehension that is
a syntax for just making lists with a very
kind of compact syntax and just making them
in one step. And so, I want to show you the
list comprehension syntax. And so my--the
problem--my first problem will be like, oh,
what if I want to make a list? Link three
of the lengths of those strings, so, kind
of parallels the list of strings. So, the
list comprehension syntax is like--I'm not
sure what adjective describes it and so on.
But anyway, here's the way I do it. So the
list comprehension syntax, what you start
off is you write a set of square brackets
and then you're going to put code inside of
there to represent the list that you want
to compute. This is the way I do it, so I
type the square brackets and I go into the
middle here. And then it--the list comprehension
syntax, it reuses as much of the existing
syntax as possible. So, the ones--the existing
syntax we know is the "for" loop. So, I say--oops.
I say, "for s in a." all right, for each string
inside of there and then, for the list comprehension
syntax. Then on the left hand side, you put
the value that it would like to use. What
function would you like it to run on each
s in this case? So, I'm going to say, "Oh,
yeah, what's len(s) for s in a?" And if I
just hit return there, that just-- in one
step, just makes the new list. So, if you
wanted to have--you have a kind of a list
of one sort, this is a--in a list, you would
call this a mapcar. If you have a list of
one sort and you want to kind of transform
it to a list of another sort, then this is
exactly what the list of comprehension does.
Now, let me show you another example. I'll
show you another feature it has. So, if I'll--let's
say I have a list with, you know, one, two,
three, four here. Oops. All right, and now
I'll write a comprehension. I'll say, "for
num in a." And let's say I wanted to do squares,
so I could say, "Oh, num times num for num
in a." So, I could just make the squares that
way. You can also add an "if" statement on
this if you want to kind of do--what you would
maybe call a filter operation. So I could
say, "Well, I want num times num for num in
a, if I don't know, num is greater than two."
And so now, this kind of runs over the list
and you're sort of slicing off some elements
and then computing this thing for it. So let
me--I'll show you just a last example. Let's
see, what directory am I in here? Oh, good.
Oh right, I'm in the copy special directory.
So, as the last example, we have that, you
know, import os. So we have that "os.listdir"
thing, right? I'll say "listdir(".")". All
right, so there's that list there. I'm just
going to--can we just write a comprehension
to just make the list of special files all
in one step? And I'm kind of pushing the envelope
a little bit here. So, I'm going to say, "import
re." So here, I'll do the square braces. So
I want to say, "For f," I'll say, you know,
for the--this is the filename--"for f in os.listdir(".")"
Okay, so now I want to say--I just want "f",
so it's "f for f in os." And then I want to
add an "if" statement here, right? I want
to say, "if re.search." And what was it? Like
"r"__\w+"..." This isn't cryptic at all. I
think that--so, let's just try it. Now, check
it out. So, there's a bunch of things kind
of getting compacted in there, right? I mean,
there's the search [INDISTINCT]. Okay, so
for small problems, the list comprehension
is very attractive. And it feels like you
have this idea in your mind--it's always nice
if you have your--an idea in your mind, and
then the amount of code to kind of express
that idea is small. You didn't feel like you
needed to add all this extra barricades and
stuff to kind of like get your idea out there.
And list comprehensions definitely have that
feeling. Although I think the syntax is a
little foreign at first. I mean, but you know,
pretty, you get kind a little bit uncomfortable
typing out. And then the mnemonic for what
it's worth is that it reuses the "for" loop
and the "if" statement as they exist and sort
of just puts them in a square bracket. That's
kind of the way to remember it, except for
the thing about the expression on the left
that you just have to commit some brain cells
to remember that one. All right, so list comprehension
is very attractive and you know, according
to the Google style guide, we would be very
happy to use these as so long as they're one
or two lines long. And now, I have to give
you this warning, this surgeon general required
warning whenever you are showing someone the
list comprehension. And the warning goes as
follows. There is this form of madness that
can take over a programmer. And the madness
is of this form. You had a program and it
was like 100 lines long, and your officemate,
you know, used a bunch of macros and weird
features that no normal person ever uses and
they got it down to like 80 lines. And you
saw what they did and you're like, "Oh, that's
nothing." And you like, use more and more
esoteric features or whatever kind of stuff
and you sort of get it down to like three
lines. You know, it's just like unbelievable.
Like and it is so satisfying. I mean, it is
actually very satisfying to feel like your
cleverness is being--just totally working
and wow, you have this thing like completely
condensed. So, the problem is that it's a
path, it like, pulls you on a path. But in
reality, what you've created is completely
unreal, right? It is not that someone could
look at that and say "What does that do?"
So, the list comprehension, I mean, it's like--it's
like that scenario I described is a risk factor.
So, the list comprehension is great for like
a couple lines long. But what you can do is
you can nest them. You can have an inter-list
comprehension that does something and then
that's nested inside of another one, inside
of another one. You can sort of take your
entire program and just have it be like this
nested list comprehension. But I would definitely
recommend that you not do that. Or as I would
say, it's kind of like with great power comes
great responsibility. So, this is a very nice
feature. If you feel like it's still readable
and sensible but just like, you know, don't
go out of control. Yeah, question?
>> Is it faster?
>> PARLANTE: Is it faster? I don't think it's
really, really faster, not--not especially.
I mean, the trick is you figure that "for"
loop like the "for" whatever append. That
is a highly optimized case. That's a super,
super common thing to do in Python. So, I
think these are both low optimized. I don't
think slower either. I mean, I guess maybe
it has some slight advantages, but I don't
think it would be significantly faster. Great,
so, I just wanted to show you that, it's just
kind of for fun. The other thing I'll mention
is that--well, I just want to talk about,
you know, Python and you, what does this mean
a little bit. So, Python is actually a pretty
popular language and its popularity seems
to have gone up a lot in recent years. And
I think, certainly in this class, you've gotten
kind of a feel of--in a sense, I've tried
to give you assignments or projects where
Python looks pretty good, right? So, Python
has--it has the nice--the list is nice, the
string is nice, the dictionary--so anything
where you're kind of pulling in data and using
those things where Python is good, those are
going to work pretty well. I think that's
one area of strength. Also, syntactically,
it's pretty short. I think that may you know,
you're not typing a lot extra stuff, and so
that makes it attractive for small problems.
And then finally, like a lot of other languages,
I think Python--you benefit from the urllib
and records, you know, all those kind of modules
that are sort of out there that you can build
on top of them. And so, yeah, out in the real
world, if you look at scientists or universities
or companies or whatever, yeah, a lot of people
find Python to be like a really nice fit for
problems they actually have, and so, I'm sure
it gets used a lot. And certainly with Google,
it gets used for like, all sorts of stuff.
And I think, I will speculate that, you know,
probably the amount of languages like Python
or JavaScript or Java or whatever is just
gradually on the way up in Google as they
save programmer time and they use a little
more memory, a little CPU, but you know, ultimately,
programmer time is something that we, is extremely
expensive and rare. And so, you know, something
that allows us to save programmer time is
a little bit attractive. So, what I would
say--and so, I'd have to give you one warning,
so Python is in fact a large language. If
you really looked at all the features that
this language has, there's a lot to it. And
we have not, we have not covered all those
things. That--just study. The good news is
you have absolutely seen the core of the language,
like the very common, straight ahead, normal
features that you would want to use to solve
a lot of problems, you have seen them. And
in fact, you've written projects that use
a lot of them. So, I would say from here on
out, you should be very comfortable if you
are--want to read a Python book or go some
Python talk at Google or whatever, like, yeah,
you've definitely seen the basic core stuff.
And so, I think you're--well, you know, well-set-up
to kind of go from here and sort of learn
more Python if you want. And my last piece
of advice about that is that I found I--the
way you learn this stuff is by writing code,
right? I mean, you can watch talks, but really,
it's about in coding. And certainly in this
class, you know, hopefully write--somebody
is solving these problems, you learn something.
And so, for myself, or say for example, within
Google, I--my Python stuff got stronger when
I started forcing myself to solve things in
Python. And so, the first offender there was
really Bash. So, things that I might've solved
as a shell script and especially--I think
Bash works well if you're just calling programs
and just sort of dumping their output to text
files, I go to that--that's fine. Or like,
I can write a correct Bash script so long
as it has, at most, one "if" statement in
it. It's like I can sort of get that right.
But if you find yourself in Bash like reeling
the data in and sorting it and uniqueing it
and cutting it into tabs and all, it's sort
of doing data processing in Bash, then I think
Python maybe looks pretty good. But if what
you could do is instead call the program from
Python but pull the data into Python for processing.
So you can use regular expressions, and [INDISTINCT],
all that kind of stuff. So I think that, as
a first next step for Python programming.
I think that's a good thing considering, you
know, definitely Python gets used in Google
a lot. All right, so that concludes--that's
the extent of the Python teaching we're going
to have today. So, thanks so much for your
attention, and I'm happy to stay longer if
you want to work on the projects and good
luck with Python in the future. All right,
thank you. Thank you.